we could go on and on and on about all
the admirers over the years for Robin
you turned down Will Smith who's a
handsome guy John stos another handsome
guy you're something else you don't even
know probably what was that guy's name
who used to have the videos with the
girls playing the instruments Robert
Palmer is that was that his name yeah
yeah Robert Palmer he came and visited
me in my little cubicle at
krock and said who are you you and I'm
like what's this guy doing in my
room oh wait a second I didn't know how
to deal with it you're telling me Robert
Palmer might as well face it I'm
addicted to love that guy when he had
done that song W and was he coming on to
you yeah why would anybody come into the
room he had looked at me really what did
he say to you he just said who are you
and what' you
say I don't know you said I don't know
who I am no wonder he R
outly I'm not cool with this whole
thing why not Robert Parmer good those
cool people what about Dennis Robin he
you could have had him
too please who want again you know and
one of and one of the Great
players Lenny D many people Lenny dyra
yeah too many people I don't like a
crowd I don't want to be part of a num
group and you know who else wanted you
real bad and you can't deny it Clarence
Clemens of the East Street Band yeah
yeah you turned him down too wanted to
get in a bathtub with you a whole thing
Joe Frasier yes I was say mention Joe
Frasier oh man every time Robin you know
Joe came to my book signing Philly I
know he did he wanted you I was like he
was serious about it he was yeah he was
very serious and when I met Muhammad
Ali uh you know I was standing there and
he you know we took a picture together
and we wound up all wrapped up around
each other but it took us a while to get
wrapped up around each other and the
photographer dropped her camera and said
are you too
finished and I said you have to forgive
us because we're falling in love and
Muhammad whispered in my ear you don't
know how right you are wow imagine you
bang Muhammad Ali no I was never going
to bang that would have been amazing and
we're not remembering uh Sam Kennis he
also had the great idea Robin we should
sleep together just think of the
headlines hey the man was a genius you
would have been an honor I'm sure I love
that guy I'm talking about famous men
want wanted to bang
Robin she said no had well I think I
think pen Gillette was upset because he
looked too much like
you what and when we walked down the
street together people would say hi
Howard just because he was with me poor
pen and I think that was the end of our
little
flirtation you know you go back in time
turns out every almost every guess had
on the show on it the [__]
[Laughter]
Rob